Setting a different value for the mass is obviously
something that has to happen in the right-hand side.
The differential equations, as such, contains our physical model.
Determining the value at one precise instant of time
is a job for the output.
Most probably it has to interpolate between values before and after,
because there is no step at exactly this instant of time.
So, this is O.
Stopping at the given time--that's a job for the driver.
It will stop the stepper.
Using an implicit method is tricky.
That's unclear.
Somebody would be responsible to solve the equation.
Who would that be?
There is no explicit right-hand side of that equation.